Com'è un volo Milano Bogotà in business
vi porto con me arrivati a Linate
abbiamo fatto colazione nella Lounge e
poi siamo saliti sul primo volo Milano -
Madrid una volta arrivati a Madrid Ci ha
raggiunto mia sorella con mockley per un
saluto Guardate come era contento ma ho
voglia di vedermi mi ha fatto un sacco
di feste poi ci siamo salutati che se la
possiamo sediliti sul secondo e ultimo
Polo Madrid al posto Ho trovato un bel
cuscino un piumino un coprisedile super
comodo che poteva essere usato anche da
ulteriore cuscinetto si è lasciato
arrotolato una volta sistemata ci hanno
dato il menù e poi siamo partiti per
entrare subito in tema Colombia mi sono
vista per la terza volta incanto Nel
mentre è arrivato prima l'antipasto con
dei formaggi e poi la pasta che se non
fosse stata scotta di gusto non era
neanche male Mi sono messa comoda mentre
non riuscivo a prendere sonno Salvo
Giarra nel mondo dei sogni poi perché
gli spagnoli traducono sempre titoli in
inglese non lo so ma nel dubbio Mi sono
rivista un grande classico decisamente
razionale chicas malas poi mi sono
dedicato a darmi una sistematina data
dell'acqua rinfrescante poi sistemato un
po' la base poi sono tornata al posto
non il mio ma quello di Salvo per un
breve momento di tenerezza è arrivato lo
spuntino che non ho mangiato perché era
pieno di peperoni e dopo 10 era di volo
siamo finalmente arrivati a poco